good evening everyone have your
attention my name is sig Gissler I'm the
administrator of the Pulitzer Prizes and
I want to welcome you on behalf of the
Pulitzer Prize board and the journalism
school each year Pulitzer Prizes in
journalism stir excitement around the
world newsrooms cheer proud grandmothers
weep champagne flows tonight however
we're going to look deeply at the work
itself tonight we're going to explore
how journalists one Pulitzers by holding
up the mirror to society thereby
bringing grave issues to public
attention and as you listen remember to
ask yourself if we did not have such
journalists who would be doing this
vital work our panel is superb starting
on your left am I left I should say and
moving across the platform we begin with
our moderator Sheila Cornell director of
the j-school stabile Center for
Investigative Journalism and my partner
in organizing the program an outstanding
investigative journalist she began a
career in the Philippines in 1982 and
won renown with the coverage of human
rights abuses that marked the end of the
Marcos regime 1989 she founded the
Philippine Center for Investigative
Journalism to promote investigative
reporting and two trained journalists
the center became a highly trusted news
source in the region reporting on
poverty corruption and other shenanigans
put it this way if you did something
wrong you would not want Sheila on your
trail the 2006 she came to the united
states to join our faculty and become
the inaugural head of the stabile center
the graduate of the University of
Philippines and the London School of
Economics Sheila's author or editor of
more than 12 books and the recipient of
numerous awards including
highest honour paid to a Columbia
professor the presidential teaching
award in 2011 next to Sheila Susan
Schneider and my Cleary representing the
Philadelphia Inquirer winner of the
public service prize with that with its
iconic gold medal displayed up there in
winning the prize they held up the
mirror to violence in the public schools
susan has covered education for the
Inquirer since she joined the paper in
1998 she was lead co-lead reporter for
the team that investigated school
violence in addition to the Pulitzer
that work one other top awards around
the country today she is on the high
higher education beat at the Enquirer
she's a graduate of Indiana University
of Pennsylvania she previously covered
education at the morning call in
Allentown in her career she's won
numerous regional state and national
reporting awards mike luery on Susan's
left knows his way around the newsroom
today he is the new editor of the San
Antonio express-news congratulations he
took that post in August after spending
33 years at the Philadelphia Inquirer
prior to leaving the paper he edited the
pulitzer-winning project were examining
tonight at the Inquirer Mike was a
reporter for nearly two decades
including stints as a national
correspondent and as a foreign
correspondent covering the fall of
communism in Eastern Europe he also said
also has had various editing
responsibilities at the paper including
investigations editor and managing
editor Mike began his career working for
his father's newspaper in rice lake a
weekly paper in rice lake wisconsin and
he is the first third-generation
graduate of our journalism school class
of 1972 his father and mother class of
1947 his grandmother class of 1917 and
his grandfather class of 1916 are all
graduates
Wow well done a night next to Susan and
Mike we have Michael J Barons an
investigative reporter for The Seattle
Times in 2012 we gave to investigative
reporting prizes one went to Michael and
Seattle Times colleague can Armstrong
they held up the mirror to deadly
reliance on methadone for pain relief
Michael previously worked on the
investigative team at the Chicago
Tribune and at the columbus dispatch
where he began at age 22 as a copy boy
while attending Ohio State University
finalist twice before in the Pulitzer
competition michael is a highly
decorated journalist named an award and
he's probably wanted selden ring award
Loeb award for business reported
national press club award he's won them
all and the list goes on and on next to
Michael we have Craig F Walker a staff
photo journalist at the Denver Post
Craig is a master of intimacy that's why
he won the Pulitzer Prize for feature
photography in 2010 and again in 2012
this year Craig held up the mirror to
the invisible wounds of our veterans
since 911 he is focused on the men women
and children tangled in the continuing
story of geopolitical conflict he
chronicled the aftermath of the collapse
of the world trade center towers the war
in Afghanistan and the deployment of
American troops in Kuwait and later Iraq
2009 his photo essay about a young baby
faced American soldier won the grand
prize in editor publishers photos of the
Year competition the next year that sa
won a Pulitzer and he's compiled many
others both national and international
Craig came to the post in 1998 from the
Berkshire Eagle in Pennsylvania and
pittsfield massachusetts i should say
where he chronicled the final six months
in the life of a woman with AIDS an
early
example of Craig's intamin storytelling
with his camera next to Craig Matt
Apuzzo and Eileen Sullivan to
washington-based reporters for the
Associated Press they were part of the
team that held up the mirror to converge
controversial spying tactics by the new
york city police department and they won
the second pulitzer awarded this year
for Investigative Reporting Matt Apuzzo
is a wide-ranging investigative reporter
he has uncovered the location of CIA
prisons and exposed how states use
stimulus money to repave good bridges
rather than fixed bridges in disrepair
before joining the investigative team he
was ap's legal affairs writer in
Washington where he covered the trial of
White House aide scooter libby earlier
he was part of the AP team in
Connecticut that exposed corruption in
state government there's a pattern here
folks he began his career as a reporter
for the standard-times in New Bedford
mass where he covered corruption and
organized crime in America's busiest
fishing town he's won or shared numerous
awards including a polk award and a
goldsmith prize for Investigative
Reporting all in all matt says he's had
more fun than he ever anticipated when
it became clear he would never get into
medical school Eileen Sullivan our last
speaker on Matt's left she seems like a
fascinating character right out of the
hit program homeland she covers
counterterrorism for the AP and
specializes in homegrown terrorism and
domestic radicalization she's covered
every significant terror plot in the US
since September 11th she previously
covered the Department of Homeland
Security for the AP and for
congressional quarterly in the federal
times she too has shared the Goldsmith
and polk awards for investigative
journalism she began a career with the
courier post in Cherry Hill New Jersey a
graduate of Villanova in 99 1999 with
in English she grew up in Alexandra
Alexandria Virginia and lives in
Washington DC now a quick word about our
format with the interview style
questions Sheila will guide the
panelists through their stories starting
with the Philadelphia Inquirer we will
devote about 15 to 20 minutes with each
segment at the end of each segment
Sheila will turn to the audience for
about five minutes of questions about
that particular segment before moving on
to the next prize so please be thinking
of questions from the outset after all
four segments are finished we will have
a general round of questions now please
use the microphones that are in the two
aisles the ones nearest to you to ask
your questions we're making a video of
the event and we want to be sure that we
capture your questions anyone tweeting
you'll see it's hashtag CJ Pulitzer now
Sheila please take it away